[Musica]
immaginatevi di essere ad una festa in
una sera d'estate è il compleanno di
monica monica compie 50 anni e del
momento della torta tutte le sono
intorno tutti gli invitati e arriva al
regalo lei lo prende in mano e una
sorpresa non sa di cosa si tratti e
della sorpresa al quale stiamo lavorando
da molto tempo tutte le persone intorno
a lei e quindi sono molto emozionate
apre il pacco e vede un libro un grande
libro colorato non capisce ed inizia a
sfogliare e poi pian piano inizia a
realizzare che quello è il libro della
sua storia
chi c'è dentro suo passato c'è dentro il
suo presente ed è fatto delle tante
piccole storie raccontate da tutte le
persone che le vogliono bene la sua
mamma ha raccontato di quando è nata i
suoi figli ne sono dei ventenni maschi
15 a far riscrivere stata un'impresa
l'hanno scritto una lettera c'è chi le
ha scritto e dedicato delle storie chi
le ha fatto delle confessioni che ha
fatto dei disegni del anche dei fumetti
persino il suo gatto c'è dentro farle
gli auguri dal gallese tradotto da
giacomo suo figlio è un'emozione
grandissima
stupore meraviglia monica poi ci ha
raccontato che bello ricevere un regalo
così il più bel regalo in 50 anni sapere
di essere nel cuore delle persone
sapere che ti stanno pensando mentre tu
non sai niente sapere che tu sei
importante per loro
dovrei nutrirmi di più di questo
pensiero ci ha detto quanto importanti
sentirci apprezzati e valorizzati
riconosciuti
io alla fine di questa ted quando farete
la standing ovation e applaudirete mi
sentirò benissimo e lo chiama effetto
sito cina si parla gestito cina come
l'ormone della gravidanza ma la sua
cucina bozak ha dimostrato che anche
quello ormone che si produce
quando diamo e riceviamo dei feedback
positivi se chi li dona sia in chi le
riceve quindi starete benissimo anche
voi dopo la standing ovation e ed è un
ormone che genera fiducia che genera
contentezza che aumenta l'empatia
eppure quante occasioni abbiamo partire
ad una persona ti voglio bene e non la
utilizziamo non ti voglio bene generico
non ti voglio bene specifico pensato
perché sei importante per me che cosa
hai fatto di importante per me perché
anche solo se una presenza importante
nella mia vita
qualche settimana fa ero il funerale del
papà di una mia amica del liceo non me
lo ricordo il papa ma sono state dette
re le parole bellissime e mentre ero lì
che ascoltavo mi dicevo come spesso mi
dico ai funerali
ma queste cose gliel'hanno mai dette
perché dirgliele quando non le poche
ascoltare non dirglielo in vita ecco me
morana e nata così intorno all'idea del
dono intorno all'idea di dare valore
creare valore per le relazioni intorno
all'idea di far circolare apprezzato
gratitudine affetto intorno all'idea di
onorare la vita la vita delle persone
la vita delle famiglie la vita delle
aziende delle imprese la vita
dell'amicizia degli amori la nostra
storia iniziata così era una grigia
mattina d'inverno sono andata bere un
caffè con rosi e parlavamo delle nostre
situazioni lavorative non così felici e
poi cercavamo idee non sono arrivate non
sappiamo ancora della curiosità e di
farsi curiosi come dicevano oggi e
quindi torna a casa e sfoglio un
articolo di un giornale che parla dei
del mestiere del personali storia
americani e boom un'esplosione nella
testa
io son vecchietta non so se qualcuno di
voi si ricorda il film blu
ho vissuto quella sensazione di john
belushi in chiesa la luce
ho visto la luce ho visto cosa ho visto
con chi ho visto cosa fare ho alzato il
telefono e ho fatto subito quattro
telefonate a quattro donne e quattro
amiche e poi ho scritto un messaggio a
maria pia e sono andata a trovarla maria
pia sta combattendo con una malattia
feroce questa malattia l'ha tolto la
parola e l'ha tolta la possibilità di
muoversi questa malattia l'ha stroncato
la vita metà la torta un lavoro che
amava tantissimo
lei è un passato da imprenditrice e
sento che la persona giusta per aiutarmi
e decide maria pia di darmi una
possibilità
così la settimana dopo siamo tutte lì da
lei e racconto la mia visione
raccoglieremo le storie delle persone
vi aiuteremo a scrivere io non sono una
scrittrice di biografie lo aiuto a
scriverle persone la loro biografia a
raccogliere le loro ricordi a
raccogliere le memorie di famiglia per
trasformarle in libri in libri
bellissimi libri veri in libri che
verranno regalati a familiare ad amici
ma soprattutto questa idea è che memo
rania sarà regalata saranno i figli
saranno i nipoti saranno i compagni che
chiederanno ai genitori nonni e
regaleranno al nostro servizio e
richiederanno di raccontare le nostre la
loro storia così tutte le donne in tutte
le ragazze salgono a bordo la mia
visione diventa una visione condivisa e
cominciamo non è il nostro mestiere
nessuna di noi ha mai fatto un libro
allora iniziamo a formare ci studiamo
creiamo flussi studiamo il mercato e ci
prepariamo finché è un certo momento
sento che è ora di cominciare con la
prima storia e bam questa volta non è un
boom di boonen ho conosciuti tanti nella
mia vita dopo questo ma anche di bando
conosciuti tanti questo buon primo è
stato che ci ritroviamo gli ep a da sole
le altre si tirano indietro troppo
presto
non so se quello che
che voglio fare non mi sento ancora
pronta e noi partiamo
partiamo con la prima biografia la
storia di opi voluta da sua figlia ci
ritroviamo da maria pia io intervisto
lei sbobinare intervistiamo leris bobina
e compone e tra lacrime di commozione
abbiamo pianto e abbiamo riso anche
tanto con facilità con fluidità
nasce il primo libro e quando opi lo
vede e lo stringe tra le sue braccia e
una commozione talmente grande che
sentiamo di aver fatto qualcosa di bello
e vogliamo proseguire così
tra tanti libri e tanti altri prodotti
che sono nati dopo il tributo quello che
è stato regalato a monica dove tanti
raccontano di uno i poster dove si
celebrano i traguardi dai 18 agli 80
anni e il laboratorio autobiografici
continuiamo e cresciamo in questi otto
anni
e a noi subiscono altre persone altre
donne sulla strada incontriamo agata
patrizia incontriamo mariangela cristina
anche raffaella e federica qui a bologna
perché raccontarvi questa storia io
credo molto nel potere delle storie la
scrittura autobiografica e una
straordinaria forma di cura di sé anche
leggere le storie di vita degli altri a
molteplici poteri ci aiuta a
comprenderci a comprendere ci può
aiutare a consolarci ci puoi stirare
mi ricordo al caso di una cliente che
era venuta da me chiedendo di aiutare la
sala ama raccontare la sua storia tra
l'altro già sentito parlare delle donne
ingegnere lei stata una prima donna a
laurearsi al politecnico nella sua
specialità ed è diventata poi
professoressa politecnico di torino
sophie lavora soprattutto ok procurarle
compagnia aiutarla darsi uno scopo che
la malattia non le permetteva più di
muoversi e di fare quanto faceva prima
ma non era tanto interessata alla sua
storia però poi quando l'ha letta quando
ho visto il libro mi ha raccontato di
come leggere e capire le difficoltà che
aveva affrontato sua mamma durante la
vita le scelte difficili che aveva fatto
l'aveva avvicinata lei effettivamente è
anche un altro caso di un cliente che ci
raccontava di come avendo regalato il
libro dei parenti aveva poi scritto una
nipote una lettera commovente
ringraziandolo per che attraverso la sua
storia la conoscenza dell'infanzia dello
zio e quello che aveva raccontato ha
potuto conoscere e capire la storia del
suo papà che non aveva mai conosciuto
insomma scrivere leggere anche donare
scrivere una storia per altri come nel
tributo chiedere di scrivere una storia
ha un grande potere è un grande dono
sapere che siamo importanti per qualcuno
e poi soprattutto io credo nel potere
delle tante piccole storie che noi
raccontiamo che raccontiamo noi stessi e
magari raccontiamo anche agli altri ci
sono storie che sono molto potenti ci
liberano ci permettono di crescere
permettono di volare come diceva oggi
uno speaker e ci sono storie invece che
ci limitano c ingabbiano ci frenano
molte di queste storie a molti di queste
storie ho ripensato ripercorrendo con la
memoria riandando con la memoria nel
nella nostro percorso di questi anni ho
ripensato alle storie che bloccano
dall'esprimere il nostro affetto
ci sarà tempo magari metto in imbarazzo
la persona non è così importante tanto
lo sa che gli voglio bene
ho pensato alle storie che ci tengono
legati ad un posto di lavoro io le
conosco molto bene con le storie
che mi raccontava che sono le storie di
dovrei devi sforzati dovresti essere
felici di avere un lavoro sicuro di
responsabilità sforzati di andare
d'accordo con tutti anche se stavo
malissimo
e se il mio lavoro in un ambiente che
non mi piaceva poi ci sono storie che ci
impedì che impediscono di lanciarci in
un nuovo lavoro
ricordate siamo partiti in sei e ci
siamo trovati in due ci sono anche le
storie che raccontiamo che ci
raccontiamo su chi siamo e chi non siamo
nati 6 un'ottima spalla non sei creativa
non sei una buona commerciale questo mi
raccontava oggi devo mettere a freno la
mia creatività che mi lancia in
tantissimi progetti soprattutto di donne
e con le donne
[Musica]
e quanto la mia capacità commerciale vi
devo dire che sono finita dai wedding
day al golf club a vendere alle madame
torinesi sono di torino e nappi
memorabile la pa torino i nostri servizi
senza pudore
ecco io credo che soprattutto noi donne
[Applauso]
soprattutto noi donne ci molti talk di
oggi ci invitano a questo abbiamo
bisogno di rompere con quelle storie che
alimentano la disistima che nutrono la
disistima
sono le storie che iniziano con io non
sono abbastanza io non sono io non posso
molto spesso ci vediamo molto meno di
quanto siamo di quanto possiamo essere
permesso straordinario sentire come le
donne rispondono solo al cento per cento
degli annunci io sono così in effetti
cento per cento
ok ste storie che ci raccontiamo sono
tante c'è ancora una storia sulla quale
voglio portare l'attenzione e della
storia intorno al tema del successo per
lungo tempo mi sono raccontata che per
avere successo
tu devi diventare universalmente famosa
ed avere un sacco di soldi se no la tua
non è un'attività di successo
bene vi dirò qua oggi che noi non siamo
diventate ricche e non siamo neanche
famose però penso siamo una realtà di
successo
il nostro successo è la gioia e la
gratitudine che ogni libro regala ai
nostri clienti agli autori ai lettori e
la relazione che creiamo con loro ieri
al tiro al telefono con renzo 93 anni
sta scrivendo la sua bellissima storia e
mi sta portando in un mondo non esiste
più
racconta di quando non si spalava la
neve ma se andava con le slitte in città
il nostro successo il team che abbiamo
creato
siamo un gruppo di donne siamo amica ci
vogliamo bene ci sosteniamo a vicenda ci
diamo feedback sinceri per migliorare e
abbiamo incastrato questa creatura nelle
nostre vite complesse se ho contato bene
abbiamo 16 figli adolescenti adesso mi
ha detto che l'adolescenza arriva fino
ai 28 quindi sono tutti adolescenti e
con i nostri lavori perché facciamo
tutte un altro mestiere
io sono coach ci sono altri coach ci
sono insegnanti ci sono artiste ci sono
giornalisti tra di noi
e poi c'è ti chiamo chiara sfida e la
sfida se si può dire ad una terza sfida
più grande questa malattia debilitante
che però non la frenata e anzi ha più
coraggio di tutte noi
e c'è di grandissimo stimolo e continua
a essere il nostro fulcro e il nostro
momento di ispirazione
sì siamo una realtà di successo le
storie che ci raccontiamo lo raccontiamo
modellano la nostra vita non ne siamo
così consapevoli soprattutto delle
storie limitanti che ci fanno soffrire e
ci fanno soffrire perché non le
scambiamo per realtà pensiamo di non
poterle cambiare
eppure se ci fermiamo
se iniziamo a fare attenzione a
raccogliere il pezzo della nostra vita
a raccontarla anche a scriverla magari
possiamo assumere una nuova prospettiva
possiamo avere uno sguardo diverso sul
nostro passato e sulla nostra vita
questo è quello che succede a molti dei
nostri clienti arrivano da noi invitati
da un figlio
generalmente da un figlio e e c'è la
prima cosa che ci dicono eh ma la mia
vita non ha niente di speciale non
merita di essere raccontata e poi
scoprono scrivendola che invece merita
di essere raccontata non tanto perché è
un dono per qualcuno ma per loro stessi
perché riannodare i fili ripercorrere
l'interpretariato di acquisire veramente
di attribuire dei nuovi significati di
comprendere le proprie scelte di dare di
nuove un nuovo senso e spesso è un
grande invito a vivere più profondamente
la scrittura
ecco
quante storie noi possiamo cambiare se
ci fermiamo un attimo e lo osserviamo e
ci chiediamo è se mi racconta un'altra
storia
se invece delle storie di impossibilità
mi raccontarsi forse possibile se trovo
qualcuno che magari mi aiuta qualcosa
che mi aiuta
se invece delle storie di non ce la
posso fare
mi chiedo cosa può aiutarmi a farlo
se invece delle storie di devo sforzo e
fatica mi racconta delle storie
desiderio di voglia di piacere di quello
che veramente importante per me e cerco
come delle azioni degli impegni per
portarlo avanti
ragionare e riflettere sulle storie ne
aiutato molto ad essere qui oggi con voi
sono stata per settimane intrappolata
nella sindrome dell'impostore io avevo
una vocina sottile che mi sussurrava
anna andreste sbagliato non so perché da
chiamato cioè in fondo non hai fatto
mica niente di così importante e memoria
non è così importante da essere
raccontate in un atleta e poi ho deciso
di raccontarmi e raccontarvi un'altra
storia grazie
[Applauso]